[Music]
ok so it's if every second right yeah
every second which means it's officially
time to start talking about III it's I'm
here we're weeks away Tigers at game of
the year your monthly no naka yeah let's
do it and so yeah I've decided to do
their own thing in d3 at 2016 setting up
their own mini convention thing you're
the official show last year Bethesda
sort of I don't know they're like
trendsetters in that respect they broke
the mold themselves by staging their own
event and they're gonna do again this
year they've decided to do their own
little Bethesda presser and then sort of
a little gameplay demo situation
afterwards at e3 2016 s work sort of
wondering I feel like we did this last
year as well to some acclaim we did it
with a certain degree of accomplishment
and we're going to try and guess what
they're going to show at e3 2016 is you
but this is a weird company right cuz
but that's a company we like oh you so
saved them with like one or two games
there you go remind yourself of all the
companies i purchased or or although
like the sort of older games that they
have and they've actually got this sort
of large suite of stuff so I've got a
list of it here but I'm gonna throw it
out there first of all Alexa what is
what do you think is a really good sure
bet for wash but that's gonna show at e3
2016 ah fallout dlc yep big piles giant
pile sure fallout dlc let's jump into
the fall i think straight away because
fallout does two things get off right
does the fallout dlc thing where we're
going to expect it right every time the
look Skyrim oblivion they've all had on
fallout 3 as well all had like lots of
TLC attach them but i was looking back
through when the games were released
thinking like that there's no way the
lens like fallout 4 new vegas or
something like that right i was looking
through it and oblivion was released in
march two thousand six paul III was at
october 2008 so that's like it's a
pretty Swift turnaround portunity rose
and fallout new vegas 10k marriage
october 2010 so it was two years later
so that would be november not this year
but the next year you could maybe say
Skyrim came out a year after new vegas
though it was like boom boom it was like
three years after the Big father but it
was like just to your afternoon Vegas
and in 40 for the gap of doing out in
Skyrim was actually quite large that was
four years so why do you think of the
outside chances Mike
full of they're announcing a new fall
aster will see you like next year uh I'd
say there low but I don't know that
timeline has me kind of second guessing
that opinion because I kind of forgot
but I assumed that these things were
like years and years of our because it
had been like seven years since we've
seen a fall a new fall out numbered for
that game so well you forget all the
time that what how long was obsidian
working on new Vegas while three was
being right okay so so I wondered that
be crazy awesome if they had someone
working on it's entirely separate
project the entire time and then just
you know did the one-two punch the
fallout 4 and whatever they do this year
yeah I mean that they have bunches of
external studios doing this stuff like
you were talking earlier machine games
you're saying like they what are they
working on like new wolfenstein starving
games and tango gameworks like tango
GameWorks put out a big hiring call last
year in June oh right Shinji Mikami said
that his like he was done directing
after evil within but like I mean it's
the door working on something the
machine games if Wolfie was that popular
there's no way they're not not gonna do
another one or something similar so
super popular very the new blood I
imagined it pretty often him last year
yeah critically well-received anyway
yeah what is is Shinji Mikami working on
anything else that we know of now that
we know of he said he was done directing
but I mean that could also mean like the
next game that comes out is like a
Shinji Mikami production and he's like
controlling or something or he could
have gone back on his word if I were him
I mean the evil within was okay yeah so
I would not want it in my directly right
go for it Joey you know go out on a
winner yeah I mean yeah that's a whole
other studio that could be working us up
and let's let's dive into some of the
ones that we know are probably going to
be shown last year we're very excited to
see some well enough footage but a
trailer for dishonor to i showing off to
new protagonist and an exciting new sort
of more futuristic version of the world
that they had or at least one that it
progressed a little bit any dishonored
fans here yeah yeah both he exiled
excited about this one Alexa yeah also a
car Alison is working on the story in
that she is god you forgot super smart
anyway sign me up that's would be
smashing what about yourself Mike yeah I
loved the first one I remember beating
that twice like within the same weekend
redoing the you know stealth playthrough
and then killing a lot of people but two
looked awesome it's what's her it's a
Liz Nellie emily elizabeth is bioshock
yeah yeah you know you're playing as her
is cool cuz you ready have somewhat of
connection to her from the first dis on
like the first dishonored had few
problems which i think which they
weren't many i mean i know a lot of i
like the game more i like we'd like to
game more than a lot of people did but
hopefully they took the time to really
like figure out iron out the wrinkles
with how the game ended if you killed a
lot of people but i'm really excited for
desire to and definitive edition came as
was like September of last year I feel
like I'm ready so if you haven't had a
chance to play it this is a pretty good
opportunity to do so yeah fingers
crossed that show some gameplay of that
at dumant another one that we're sort of
waiting to see more of they've been
doing if in shopping it around and
showing in places like what's owed why
do you think I do but yeah because
because it's gonna it's gonna come and
people are gonna like it yeah but
whether or not it's going to be like a
super leaps and bounds ahead of the last
one I think we've yet to really see
because it just sort of looks like more
doom but prettier doom just would add
the Hello Kitty flashlight mod yes I
mean eventually I'll just put that back
in and we'll be good yeah it's weird i
don't know how i feel about do mike i'm
a big d'un faune i love all three doomed
like i'm a big quake fine i'm just a big
massive big fan overall and i noticed
something about this one is just like
the trying to split the difference
between multiplayer in single player and
it's maybe not clicking with me but
we'll see it's like whenever they
comment on the press commerce are like
yeah doom all the things you love it's
better gore and monsters and and walking
through corridors and like that's kind
of not what doing what like that's
that's on a thing when we look back at
do and it's got like oh yeah that's what
it looks like and when you like look at
it in terms of other first-person
shooters there's so much about doing it
was like about fear and about you know
yeah they're being scared and about
being lost which like I feel like three
completely missed out on and well I did
like trying to copy a bit but didn't
read it bit more single-player folks i
hope this one does this one looks a bit
you like yeah i'm killing [ __ ]
which is like kind of not what do marie
was not as we'll see i guess at ellis
goes online any ESO fans here haha and
he is so bands anywhere you right there
do you want something let us know in the
comments that was during the
announcement that for their press
conference were last week earlier this
week yesterday Pete Hines yesterday
changing things didn't they mention
elder scrolls I figured it would just be
elder scrolls online dude last year they
they
I'm not so I think you know this down
near them the the LA convention center
there is the the three the sort of
famous three buildings that always have
like a big video game poster was a big
Elder Scrolls online thing yes and I
feel like they I think it's I think at
the testimony to what they announced and
that I can't remember what it was wasn't
Tamriel unlimited by any chance was it
the console and I'm a June of last year
yeah they had announced that already but
I feel like they announced some like
free to play smaller thing right well
there you go it was a great
announcements but it's yeah so I
wondered like laughs that was a big
thing for them the fact that that was
around the same time xiii that time
really limited sort of kicking off or I
guess I probably had by the time he
three came around and they had a lot of
problems with like access and their
subscription model when it first started
coming out and then they delayed ly
think the they delayed the console
versions hmm I just think that I feel
like they lost a lot of goodwill with
that and maybe they want to put that
behind us so if they're gonna do an
elder scrolls announcement it has to be
a game I don't think anyone wants to
hear about online anymore yeah to be
honest in the same sort of I guess realm
of enjoying fantasy worlds there was a
lot of rumors before far for as well
that there was going to be some sort of
a reveal of a you know Skyrim each task
arm HD a Skyrim game ported to the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one to
current-gen consoles that interest you
at this stage yeah absolutely great yes
and no I I have a permanent itch to play
skyrim i love fallout three but Skyrim i
played so much of it and then i remember
i got it on ps3 as well just to like
start over and play anew with it but
play that really good version yeah like
the vast majority the time I don't feel
the need to go back to remasters if
they're not you know like resonable 0 is
a different story that's know how many
years old but Skyrim I would have no
problem just oh I'd excuse me players
any hours but my ps4 yeah I'd be all for
that what's Skyrim would co-op babby oh
my oh my thing all right throw up alex
is back on board wait a minute wait a
minute know if they did Skyrim where it
was like two people in the world I think
I could get behind that everybody dope
right yeah something a little new you
need that right with your HD remake
sometime you just need a little bit of
sprinkling of extra just something
maybe so maybe come in several start a
brand new show about that on a current
gen console I shout out to those
gentlemen and we miss from last year a
couple more other sort of on the
periphery things might happen uh we
talked about woven stein little bit we
talked about do you think they'll ever
do another evil within or like dive back
into that I can't see that having not
much cash Amon yeah if they do if they
do the evil within it can't be a sequel
it can't be connected to the to the
first one because the first one was just
so like I don't know they over-promised
unlike its OGG mikami father of horror
visit a well-liked here's all the scary
stuff and it didn't really like it had
some really good moments but its
treatment of sort of like craziness and
like mental illness as like a scary
thing was not really well done and I
feel like it only halfway delivered on
that premise so if they do an evil
within it has to be like they could but
it has to be like a whole new thing okay
that yeah event wet what wet too I don't
can ever discussion last year wet too
wet hung up on what wet it's a fisherman
it's literally the dumbest video game
name of all time so I just want to see
more right wetter yeah drenched what
soaked damn is damp more moist no wait
so champ that could be a way yeah you're
right it's a prequel Moyes it's an
argent story no wet well yeah don't go
back to know don't ya think Chris waters
loves wet what I have an outside kind of
appreciation for weird third person I'd
yeah but Chris waters also likes evolve
a lot no let's not get back here look at
the scars from Game of the Year are
still low pressure still fresh so let's
let's move on and then the last one I
guess that I have here there was
whenever I go back in Sicily looking up
at the history of all out there was this
ever-present narrative which ran for
about 10 years about the rights over
fall out online and there was like there
was three different companies at one
stage I thought they had it right now
but there's the owns it again there was
a payout it was like it's all sort of
clean and done now I'm Bethesda now once
again owns the rights and to to fall
that online interplanar editor quite a
little picture so like can you see that
being something that might because it's
weird because in a weird elder scrolls
online in your head you'd imagine that
that should have been more successful
but do you think maybe fall I could be
game that makes that more exciting last
I was just wondering I just Elder
Scrolls before it released and
everything here before it when you know
whatever they're doing with it now I
thought that would be huge i thought i
would be into it i played i didn't
really like it that much and i know a
lot of people were kind of soured on it
but i don't know if there's enough
momentum right on fallout 4 is released
and you know how how good a lot of
people thought it was to actually get
people interested to fall out online i
think from the perspective of the
history of you know like you said
handing the right route that be I'd be
interested to see what would happen with
that I don't necessarily know that i'd
be interested it from a player
standpoint so that's a huge not answer i
know i don't i don't think that would
happen but that'd be pretty cool to see
i like so anything I could you use mods
and follow it online because I think
that would be pretty excellent i am not
going anywhere without my mod that turns
the grenade into a baby that is an
interesting aspect of interns a grenade
into a baby it turns out there's one mod
for pc where it turns out the mini nuke
yeah into the baby at the baby gift from
the beginning okay effort is the baby
and so when you pull back and you shoot
just you shoot baby crying babies you
just shoot Bebe's that is like a very
interesting aspect of what like Wi-Fi
works is that it is a game they like you
can model obviously like green create a
crazy way of playing it we do can i play
that game the way you want to play it
like it's very much about your version
of it yeah maybe not maybe an online
thing is a bit to prescribe dealing with
other people everyone wants to be the
best wastelander i can see that i can
see a positive and people maybe like
forming colonies and bands and like
right yeah and you can have gang wars
but then i also see it as like people
that are so used to playing fallout for
their way maybe having a little bit of
friction between the people that they
want to play with mmm yeah they'll be
that one guy that's just a gem is always
around I I mean someone's gonna mod
phone I forward to do multiplayer anyway
right well that's why it's helped that's
why elder scrolls online kind of turned
me off because it lost the magic of
exploring something on your own that
Skyrim had yeah I mean it's not the heat
then what are they called a hero ramp or
whatever it is we're like in a game
where you're like by the end you're like
all's you know all saving deity yeah
well a lot of mine elder scrolls online
didn't make you feel special I think
just Elder Scrolls games do mmm what if
they just said [ __ ] it but elder scrolls
six let's do it at three yeah what am I
wouldn't what's the new world
scroll six are Black Marsh Marla no
black markets where the argonian czar
from I don't oh my god Margit I likes a
black marks ready argonians from but is
it just a mutt rock is yeah but this
Marlin was one big swamp that's where
the Dark Elves I guess yeah uh I people
it's the caviar from the cat people are
from this is great this game i play my
kids excited is a closet elder scroll
down to tomorrow and you got Black Marsh
we got Sarah dil of course which was
oblivion yeah Skyrim what Hammerfell so
that that's the thing i don't think this
would actually be named after the region
because if you look back at the games it
alternates it was like daggerfall the
name of the place but the one before
that was arena arena and then three was
morrowind which is the region before was
oblivion which was in Sierra del 5
skyrim which is where it's at so I home
I according to a convention I don't
think six would be called like Black
Marsh thing would be elder scrolls abyss
or something like sorry I do trade
markets right marketing hole exactly
yeah other Scrolls six orifice I'd into
it Black Marsh would work for our
offices well Valen would elsewhere
hammer fell in high rock or the other
ones and of course the Somerset all
which was an expansion pack right yeah
yes for president there it is right
there look at it great and then we'll
just end up in time Henry L will just go
to world of warcraft London good job
Jonna where I mean there it is Andy
crossover expansion all right okay thank
you so much ladies and gentlemen for
talking to me about the wonders of
Bethesda well you forgot one game oh
[ __ ] battle cry oh my god oh I did
everyone forgot battle across so what's
the status cuz they did just say oh
we're putting on no over a little bit
yeah I did that feature last month about
like where did all these games go and I
when I talked to them they gave me the
same song and dance that they gave us
back in the fall which was like we are
evaluating battle cry because we didn't
like it and nobody liked it and we don't
really know what to do with it and like
my theory is that and thats to do battle
cry studios which was made to
specifically make battle cry is now
working on quote unquote multiple
projects really my theory what I've
heard and what I think is happening is
battlecry Studios is now a support
studio working on other games and
supporting all of the other studios
while battle cry sort of sits in limbo
and they try to figure out what to do
with it because they came out and they
were like oh it's a hero shooter but
it's not and they're too afraid to
really call it a MOBA nobody wants to
call their game a MOBA because MOBAs are
for nerds and then that third person and
then that third person is just like well
maybe like I think right now it doesn't
have won a spot in the release schedule
yes if we're talking about all those
games that we were talking about before
and to um I think maybe they just not
grasping it and if that project goes
away I mean I don't know if anyone will
really miss it like it was really cool
I'm even seen as a battle born an
overwatch in battle cry were kind of you
know to a lot of people were doing
something seven though they weren't
there using the grey scimitar right and
something new and similar I guess yeah
it's a shame there was art director from
half-life 2 was on that right yeah uh
forgot the gentleman's name kind of
looked like dishonored right it kind of
like I wouldn't be surprised if they
were helping have dishonored probably
are you kind of see there you go alright
Chad by Lucroy I guess will be a while
before hear something like that maybe
we'll see some more Bethesda's III 2016
showcase we will have to wait and find
out thank you so much Michael Hardy alex
rae career coming on talk to me about
bethesda and when you guys think what do
you think is going to be shown at e3
2016 but there's a little hideaway let
us know in the comment box below